[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et de reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi 15 décembre a
lieu confinement bonjour couvre feu il
vient d'entrer en vigueur
à l'instant à 20 heures précises le
conseil scientifique préconise l'auto
confinement avant les fêtes de fin
d'année le monde de la culture lui ne
digère pas les trois semaines
supplémentaires de fermeture les
professionnels des syndicats du secteur
ont manifesté leur colère à paris et de
rang plusieurs grandes villes de france
aujourd'hui
vladimir poutine félicite à son tour joe
biden désigné par les grands électeurs
président élu hier le dirigeant russe
qui affirme vouloir collaborer avec le
futur locataire de la maison blanche et
qui exprime sa conviction que la russie
les états unis peuvent malgré leurs
désaccords résoudre de nombreux
problèmes et défis dans le monde
[Musique]
google se dit ce soir inquiet d'une
nouvelle législation qui ciblerait une
poignée d'entreprises
un peu plus tôt la commission européenne
a dévoilé ces deux projets de loi visant
à imposer des règles aux gaffes à
objectifs notamment éviter les dérives
comme les discours de haine diffusés à
grande échelle ou bien encore la
manipulation de l'information à la clé
des sanctions dissuasives en cas de non
respect
[Musique]
plus besoin des prestations dont pour
circuler en france mais un couvre feu
depuis une minute et 53 secondes précise
jusqu'à 6 heures demain matin l'hexagone
ce déconfite mais avec prudence à la
proche des fêtes le conseil scientifique
recommande ainsi lauton confinement
pendant une semaine ceux qui souhaitent
se retrouver en famille famille est les
restaurants bars et cafés eux restent
fermés sans garantie d'une réouverture
le 20 janvier
pas de déconfinement non plus pour le
secteur de la culture dans la rue cet
après midi on en parle dans un instant
mais avant cela retour sur les nouvelles
règles sanitaires avec notre reporter
kirill kotick of bonsoir kiri comment
les parisiens réagissent t-il à ces
nouvelles mesures
bonsoir stéphanie et bien écoutez les
parisiens l'attendait avec impatience ce
déconfinement mais ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'ils sont ce soir un peu déçu puisque
ce déconfinement aura d'autres contrats
avec ce couvre feu qui vient d'entrer en
vigueur jusqu'à demain 6 heures du matin
je me trouve rue montorgueil vous le
voyez derrière moi habituellement c'est
une rue très passante très commerçante
et là il n'y a quasiment personne une
voiture de police vient de passer à
l'instant pour contrôler quelques
personnes alors il ne sort pas encore du
véhicule pour demander les attestations
aux parisiens mais en tout cas ces
attestations devront être présentés à
tout pour toute personne qui sera sorti
dehors
lors de ce couvre feu alors il ya seule
possibilité pour sortir ce sont les
motifs impérieux familiaux médicaux
accompagnant des personnes en situation
de handicap pour sortir les animaux de
compagnie est également à noter que le
sport en plein air telles que le footing
ne rentre pas dans cette liste au tout
au long de l'après midi nous avons pu
rencontrer quelques parisiens ici rue
montorgueil pour leur demander leur avis
sur ce qu'il pense de ces nouvelles
mesures et ce qui est sûr c'est qu'ils
sont loin d'être enchanté je vous
propose de les écouter
si n'importe quoi il faut les
attestations un jour il faut des
attestations pour la journée un jour il
faut pour le soir en fait on sait plus
on en est pour moi à l'heure actuelle je
pensais qu'ils avaient même plus besoin
d'attestation ni pour le soir ni pour la
journée
et en fait on se rend compte qu'on est
encore dans ces histoires d'attestation
et que personne ne comprend plus rien
bah ouais je prends part d'un joueur n'a
pas aux besoins mais
le soir oui souffre il faut se déplacer
que si on est obligé on est obligé ovale
attestation d'halloween
les gens vont et viennent comme ils
veulent se mélanger comme ils veulent
n'importe où toute la journée et puis le
soir plus rien alors que le sort on est
en hiver je dire les gens l'hiver mais
en fait donc
c'est relativement cohérent ces infos
confinement je trouve ça normal
cette annuelle qui suit liberté au moins
la fidak cessation ça nous permet de
circuler entre certaines heures dont un
peu plus de mouvement on peut plus aller
faire les boutiques
donc un peu plus de fluidité donc ça
vient et puis comme ça ça permet aux
gens de rentrer chez eux et d'éviter de
propager le virus
si on peut faire attention avec ça
pourquoi pas mais les attestations c'est
pour la nuit donc comme il ya le couvre
feu
bon bah voilà à partir de 20 heures je
suis chez moi si j'ai envie de sortir
pour de bonnes raisons
j'ai une attestation c'est pas compliqué
et je rappelle que ce fameux couvre-feu
ne sera pas en vigueur dans la nuit du
réveillon du 24 décembre en revanche il
sera de nouveau à l'ordre du jour pour
la nuit de la saint sylvestre du 31
décembre au 1er janvier
merci qu'il kotick of en direct donc
depuis la rue montorgueil à paris et
malgré l'annoncé ce matin du premier
ministre d'une rallonge de 35 millions
d'euros pour soutenir le secteur de la
culture
les professionnels étaient dans la rue
aujourd'hui mobilisation partout en
france à paris regardez beaucoup de
monde rendez vous a été donné à la mi
journée place de la bastille et à
l'appel de la cgt spectacle
plus d'un millier de manifestants s'ils
sont rassemblés mobilisation le disais
dans tout le pays notamment à marseille
où les syndicats réclament eux aussi un
dialogue avec le gouvernement
c'est une gabegie absolue c'est un
mépris absolu de la part de notre
gouvernement vis-à-vis de nos métiers ça
fait des mois et des mois qu'on demande
à être entendu
il n'y a pas de concertation ni avec les
syndicats ni avec les élus les choses
sont faites à l'emporte-pièce on a
effectivement cette politique du yo yo
qui déstabilisent énormément à croire
que c'est fait exprès et le public lui
aussi est tout à fait en demande dans la
période actuelle qui est très anxiogène
en demande
de voir un ailleurs d'avoir un tout
petit peu de rêve dans la période des
fêtes si même encore on nous le permet
mais sachant que nos lieux de spectacles
de cinéma ne sont pas des clusters et
préserve absolument les conditions
sanitaires du public et des artistes
on a la colère du monde de la culture
après le changement donc de cap du
gouvernement inquiet l approche des
fêtes de fin d'année et avec les
réunions que vont faire les français que
jean castex recommande même à ceux qui
le peuvent de ne pas envoyer leurs
enfants à l'école je n'y ai vendredi
c'est à dire dans deux jours elle place
à notre décryptage avec nos invités et
pour en parler nous sommes avec jean
pierre villa président du syndicat de
l'exploitation cinématographique du
centre-sud bonsoir jean pierre villa
merci d'être avec nous à vos côtés
benjamin ma professeure d'histoire porte
parole cgt 94 bonsoir benjamin amar
merci également à vous d'être en
direction est et france ce soir on
commence par ces manifestations du
secteur de la culture on a vu ces images
beaucoup monde à rentrer dans les rues
de paris
aujourd'hui notamment en province
également théâtre cinéma devrait rouvrir
de v1 rouvrir aujourd'hui mais enfin
finalement ça n'a pas lieu une
mobilisation la hauteur de votre
collègue jean-pierre villa oui je crois
que le monde de la culture globalement
est tout à fait dans une situation
complètement incompréhensible comme l'a
dit un désintérêt interview précédent
nous avons eu 1 5 million de spectateurs
pendant l'été lorsque les cinémas
étaient rouverts il n'y a pas eu un seul
plus terre il n'y a pas eu un seul cas
de continue de contamination à
l'intérieur des cinémas donc la cie de
la décision qui a été prise vous paraît
totalement incompréhensible elle vous
paraît aussi tu as fait injuste dans la
mesure où l'une ni condé
aussi bien dans les théâtres grade que
dans les cinémas des protocoles
sanitaires extrêmement sérieux
extrêmement précis et nous les
respectons totalement et lilian à notre
sens pas plus de dangers à venir au
cinéma qu'à fréquenter un grand manager
ou la rue montorgueil comme celle
démontrée dans les images précédentes on
va faire évidemment benjamin amar sur ce
thème de la culture également mais bon
je voudrais vous faire avoir cette
hashtag qui a vu le jour sur les réseaux
sociaux culture en danger pas mal de
politiques se sont emparés pour faire
passer des messages
regardez par exemple celui de constance
le grip la députée les républicains des
hauts-de-seine
j'exprime toute ma solidarité et mon
soutien au monde de la culture dont je
partage la déception et la colère
monsieur le président emmanuel macron
entendez l'amertume des professionnels
de la culture et notre tristesse à tous
benjamin a marre vous on nous a souvent
eu pour militer pour la fermeture des
écoles vous jugiez sa nécessaire
aujourd'hui quelle est votre réaction
quand vous voyez que finalement les
cinémas les théâtres restent fermés
c'est une bonne chose là aussi où vous
le critiquez alors d'abord souvenons
nous a effectivement on a participé à
des débats ensemble ce que vous évoquez
c'était effectivement au mois de mai
deux mois du mois de juin où
effectivement nous assumions et nous
assumons toujours d'avoir exigé à ce
moment là la fermeture des écoles mais
savait lénine disait analyse concrète de
la situation concrète
aujourd'hui c'est le deuxième
confinement fatalement les la situation
n'est pas la même et on n'a pas les
mêmes analyses qu'on avait au mois de
mai au mois de juin aujourd'hui en
décembre surtout on essaye d'avoir un
peu de cohérence moi j'écoutais ce que
disait l'interlocuteur précédent et je
rejoins tout à fait ce qu'il dit jean
castex a dit tout à l'heure que y eut
certes il y à une exception culturelle
mais ça n'est pas une exception
une exception sanitaires mais en fait ce
que fait le gouvernement c'est une
exception culturelle à l'envers on peut
dire les choses d'une manière assez
simple
moi je parlais avec un camarade de la
cgt culture tout à l'heure il me disait
on peut aller écouter un morceau de bach
dans une église
nous on ne veut pas aller écouter un
morceau de bach dans une salle de
concert
c'est moi je prends les transports en
commun tous les jours alors on prend le
métro sans problème dans les heures de
pointe on est agglutinée les uns contre
les autres mais par contre dans les
lieux de culture
visiblement la même situation et même
d'ailleurs avec le protocole sanitaire
que l'interlocuteur précédent évoqué là
c'est impossible on a un monde de la
culture qui est exemple on a un
gouvernement qui visiblement considèrent
que l'économie financière ça doit
tourner à plein mais que le la vie
culturelle c'est autre chose en même
temps quand on entend ce qu'a dit
marlène schiappa hier par exemple sur le
pcf sur le parti communiste français qui
en 1905 ne tenait pas le même discours
alors qu'en 1905 le parti communiste
français n'existait pas on comprend
visiblement que pour les maquereaux nist
la culture générale s'en soit pas
essentiel jean pierre villa c'est vrai
qu'on a du mal à comprendre parce qu'on
a entendu des discours des manuels
macron consacré d'ailleurs exclusivement
à la culture et là on nous parle de
mépris on a entendu
effectivement cet interlocuteur dans
notre reportage des syndicats qui
s'estime pas entendu pas de concertation
la politique du yo yo c'est de ça
finalement que vient la colère
aujourd'hui du monde de la culture plus
que pour la fermeture en elle-même
finalement arrêté je crois que c'est
l'expression les décisions
gouvernementales exprime un choix très
précis que mon collègue françois aymé
président de l'association française des
cinémas réussi résume de la façon
suivante oui aux consommateurs non aux
spectateurs c'est vraiment un choix qui
fait d'une de privilégier la
consommation par rapport la culture je
pense que le gouvernement prend ses
responsabilités et que voilà le je pense
que le monde de la culture sera en temps
voulu de rendre la monnaie de la pièce
va voilà c'est nous avons le sentiment
d'une totale injustice le sentiment
d'une totale injustice qui a en même
temps des conséquences dramatiques
rendons nous compte que lorsque nous
reprendrons éventuellement
à la fin du mois de janvier nous aurons
passé 200 jours de fermeture
quelle est l'entreprise puisque un
théâtre comme au cinéma sont aussi des
lieux d'expression plurielle mais aussi
des entreprises comment dans ces
conditions même avec des aides qui
peuvent exister comment dans ces
conditions du dynamisme continu et à
fonctionner avec 200 jours de fermeture
sur 360 aujourd'hui dans des laines de
35 millions d'euros
elle ne compte pas il ne pèse pas où
elle ne suffit pas série 10 35 millions
d'euros pour la culture c'est totalement
ridicule
le premier ministre au moment où il a
fait sa déclaration d'amour au cinéma
lorsqu'il est venu au festival
d'angoulême a mis en avant un à un
une enveloppe de 160 millions qui
devaient arriver au cnc qui est
peut-être arrivé au samedi les cinémas
là-dessus allons récupérer environ 30
millions quelle est la remarque en
incroyable écart qu'il ya entre les 175
millions théorique qui devait être
versée au centre ancien du sien et les
35 millions qui aujourd'hui sont
destinés à l'ensemble de la culture
je pense que on surmonte le louvre
actuellement en tout cas à quelques
jours des fêtes de fin d'année un le
gouvernement semble très inquiet de voir
les contaminations exploser le conseil
scientifique recommande même à ceux qui
le peuvent de ne pas mettre leurs
enfants à l'école en fin de semaine pour
s'auto confiné je me propose d'écouter
jean castex le conseil scientifique dit
quelque chose je passe de très
raisonnable il dit d'abord si vous le
pouvez d'ailleurs si ce qui se pratique
dans certains pays étrangers dont
beaucoup auto confiné vous huit jours
avant noël si vous pouvez ce n'est pas
possible vous êtes mouillés cette
recommandation bien entendu pour ta
chaque fois que cela est possible
surtout si on doit recevoir à noël des
personnes vulnérables
le conseil scientifique je veux dire
qu'on l'appuie a même dit si vous pouvez
ne pas amener vos enfants à l'école
jeudi et vendredi
c'est la période de huit jours vous le
faites alors benjamin a marre vous êtes
professeur d'histoire j'ai envie de vous
poser la question comment on s'organise
on
bonjour alors on met des enfants mais
pas les enfants comment comment ça se
passe
j'ai écouté le passage que vous venez de
transmettre et j'ai failli tomber de ma
chaise honnêtement moi je considère
qu'on fait dans cette pandémie
elle révèle beaucoup de choses d'abord
elle révèle en réalité l'état
je dirais le la fragilité et la
vulnérabilité des services publics
finalement impactée depuis depuis un
certain nombre d'années par les
politiques libérales qui ont cassé les
moyens et en plus on a comme double
effet kiss cool l'incohérence de ce
gouvernement qui me donne l'impression
sur tous les sujets en lien avec cette
pandémie de courir partout comme un
poulet sans tête
honnêtement je n'y a rien qui tient quoi
nous en tant qu'enseignant on a dû se
bagarrer se mobiliser à la rentrée de la
toussaint
parce que en fait le gouvernement nous
disait tout va très bien où on gardait
les mêmes flux regardait exactement le
même protocole on nous disait juste
d'ouvrir les fenêtres
voilà il a fallu qu'on se mobilise
pendant une dizaine de jours pour
obtenir enfin un peu plus d'une semaine
pour obtenir enfin effectivement de
l'adaptation la souplesse pour
travailler en 2000 groupe etc
c'est pas satisfaisant mais au moins
effectivement ça limitait la propagation
du virus et à l'époque on avait un
gouvernement qui traînaient des cas de
faire un ministère qui traînaient des
quatre fers et là ils nous disent à quoi
à quelques jours des vacances vous savez
quoi auto confirmez vous mais enfin je
veux dire honnêtement mais quelle
cohérence il ya là dedans quels moyens
je sais plus quoi dire à mes élèves en
face les élèves eux mêmes ils sont dans
une situation et il ya beaucoup d'ironie
et de sarcasmes voilà bah ça me dit que
voulez vous je pense que pour reprendre
un adjectif qui emmanuel macron aime
bien l'autre le taux d'auto confinement
samedi matin parce que moi j'ai cours
samedi matin avec mes élèves
il va être croquignolesque voilà mais me
dire qu'est ce qu'on a comme comcast la
bête parents d'élèves
benjamin justement quand guignolet ça
veut dire quoi vous pensez que ça va
être suivi tous les badges je pense que
je me trompe peut-être à vous ses
parents non mais il ya beaucoup
d'évaluation en fin d'année alors on se
demande
parent finalement on est partagés on se
dit ben voilà on va pénaliser nos
enfants de ne pas les mettre et dans le
même temps on va peut-être pénalisé les
grands parents qu'on va avoir quelques
jours plus tard donc c'est vrai que ça
mais une responsabilité sur le dos des
parents qui est importante et est
compliquée peut-être à gérer alors vous
avez tout à fait raison de toutes les
façons il faut savoir que la patate
chaude
le ministère en réalité la balance lors
du premier confinement c'était pour les
mères vous vous souvenez ou rejeter la
responsabilité sur les mers ensuite
monsieur blanc caire nous a expliqué au
mois de novembre
confie d'allemands c'était localement
dans les établissements publics
notamment dans les lycées que l'on
pouvait voir comment est-ce qu'on
aménage et les choses bon voilà et là
maintenant effectivement il ya beaucoup
de choses qui repose sur les familles
mais dans le monde réel dans le monde
réel dans la vraie vie moi je suis prof
depuis 20 ans un samedi par exemple un
vendredi ou un samedi matin de veille
scolaire va de veille de vacances
scolaires la densité dans les classes
avaient pas optimale avec cette annonce
du du gouvernement il est évident qu'on
va se retrouver moi je suis sûr que dans
ma classe je vous dirai si ma prédiction
est mauvaise mais je risque de me
retrouver avec deux pelés et trois
tondus samedi matin en classe mais
j'entendais monsieur castex tout à leur
dire évoqué comment ça se passe dans
d'autres dans d'autres pays
c'est marrant parce que le goût pour la
comparaison européenne il est à
géométrie variable sur votre antenne au
mois de mai quand comme mon syndicat je
signalais qu'en italie par exemple on
avait décidé de reporter la rentrée
scolaire à septembre le gouvernement
pousser des cris d'orfraie et la
maintenance ce castex nous dit mais là
bas ailleurs ça se passe comme ça
faye a aucune cohérence je pense le
gouvernement ne sait plus où il habite
le problème c'est que nous derrière on
est impacté par ce gouvernement qui
ressemble encore une fois un poulet sans
tête jean-pierre vidal le mot de la fin
vous vous et les veaux auto confiné
quelle est votre réaction par rapport à
ce conseil parce que c'est vrai que
c'est pas une obligation d'auto
confinement c'est vrai que ça mais les
français dans une situation qui peut
peut-être particulière et confuse je
pense que nous sommes toute la
profession est dans un état de choc
nous avons beaucoup investi pour offrir
aux spectateurs une des vacances de noël
une fin d'année qui soit un peu plus
optimiste que un peu plus festive que ce
qu'il y avait été ce cas était 2020 nous
le proposions en toute sécurité et
l'investissement qui a été fait a
brutalement été arrêté par par ce coup
d'arrêt ekstrom enfants la seule le seul
point positif c'est la certitude que les
spectateurs attendent la réouverture du
cinéma attend de la réouverture de
théâtre parce que la vraie vie elle et
pas devant l'internet
elle est pas sur les réseaux elle n'est
pas sur les plates formes la vraie vie
la vraie vie culturelle de la vie
sociale elle est dans les théâtres
elle est dans les cinémas elle est dans
le dans la relation humaine est
aujourd'hui j'espère qu'on n'est pas en
train de vous préparer une société tout
le numérique
n'oublions pas que les arbres se
découvre sur un plateau de théâtre les
oeuvres se découvre sur un grand écran
en partage entre l'ensemble des
spectateurs et ces choses là aujourd'hui
sont remises en cause et c'est
extrêmement compliqué extrêmement dur
mais on garde l'espoir d'un d'une
possible renaissance
lorsque les conditions sanitaires seront
meilleures ou que l'on voudra bien
regarder la réalité dans le
fonctionnement de l'ensemble
le dossier était un club de ces cinémas
français seront certainement au rendez
vous les français qui ont bien besoin
voilà de deux cultures pour leur
remonter le moral en ce moment merci à
tous les deux jean pierre villa merci
également à benjamin a marre
autre mobilisation à paris celle des
soignants un rassemblement devant le
ministère de la santé à l'appel des
syndicats cgt et sud les manifestants
demandent une augmentation de la
rémunération des professionnels du
secteur médico social et des personnels
territoriaux associative et privée et
s'estiment exclus du ségur de la santé
nadège abderrazak étaient sur place
ils sont en colère et veulent le faire
savoir plusieurs centaines de salariés
du secteur social médico-social et du
handicap ont manifesté en début d'après
midi devant le ministère de la santé
ils sont arrivés des quatre coins de la
france de l'île de lyon ou encore de
brest et ils dénoncent leur situation
d'oublier du grand ségur de la santé ils
estiment eux aussi avoir été en première
ligne depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire ils réclament une augmentation
de salaire de 183 euros comme ça a été
le cas pour les soignants un budget
supplémentaire pour le recrutement des
équipes d'effectifs supplémentaires
ainsi que la reconnaissance de la
pénibilité du travail
reçu au sein du ministère de la santé la
délégation syndicale est reparti
bredouille puisque aucune des
revendications n'a été acceptée je vous
propose de l'écouter certains
manifestants même métier égal même
salaire aussi qui est logique
elano coléreuse notre colère est
justifié
nous n'avons pas en face des gens
capables de nous répondre sur
l'obtention de ses 183 euros et je suis
très déçu oui parce que je pensais qu'on
aurait au moins guinée même si on a eu
du co2 ça ne reste qu'une écoute et nous
n'avons pas de réponse et nous
continuerons tant que nous n'aurons pas
de vraies réponses
alors moi je suis réunis parce que je
travaille dans un foyer d'accueil
médicalisé qui avec des personnes
handicapées est en fait dans la même
association
il ya un ehpad eux ils ont une
augmentation de 183 euros et pas nous on
fait exactement le même travail voilà et
on est là pour revendiquer ça pour qu'on
ait les mêmes droits tout le monde a
fait le même travail tout le monde de
donner le meilleur de soi et il ya des
injustices même à tous les niveaux même
au niveau de la prime qu'ovide vous par
exemple nous nous sommes dans un
établissement le foyer de l'enfance et
il n'y a que certaines personnes qu'ils
ont d'autres l'ont pas donc
incompréhensible et là le secure ces
couches de trop quoi moi personnellement
je suis je travaille dans un hôpital
psychiatrique
je fais partie de l'ensemble il se
trouve que j'ai des collègues qui
travaillent dans le même qui ont le même
directeur
le même employeur surtout que beckham
mais mes collègues et soignants mpm wiam
hier éducatrice qui travaillent dans le
même établissement n'a pas le même
salaire même employeur est pas le même
salaire
ce tout c'est une injustice très très
grave des manifestants qui est annonce
d'ores et déjà la poursuite de leur
mouvement ils ont d'ailleurs prévu de
revenir manifester dans les semaines
dans les mois à venir ici même devant le
ministère de la santé pour faire à
nouveau entendre leurs revendications
mais pour en parler nous sommes avec un
an et demi à ban
présidente du collectif inter urgence
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous comment
vous expliquer le fait que certains soit
exclue justement de cette loi bonsoir
expliqué je vais avoir du mal à
l'expliquer parce que je ne le comprends
pas nous faisons tous le même métier
nous avons tous des mêmes difficultés
avec des secteurs différents
la division que crée le gouvernement
depuis le début de cette banderille que
ce soit avec l'augmentation salariale
pour les hospitaliers ou la prime
qu'ovide selon selon les établissements
et services est là pour diviser on a
bien l'impression l'expliquer je peux
pas l'expliquer allez c'est pas juste
ce mouvement aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on
voit qu'il ya de la colère est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment tout de même
d'être entendu vous continuer les
consultations avec le gouvernement
on continue bien sûr parce que on n'est
pas entendu on n'est pas entendu comme
il se doit en tout cas et on doit
continuer de se battre pour se faire
entendre et faire un temps de la voie
des des paramédicaux donc c'est un peu
plus difficile aujourd'hui de mobiliser
dans la rue parce que parce que l'onuci
nous nous sommes beaucoup pris sur sur
l'ongle respectifs dans nos hôpitaux
basculement du personnel malgré les
promesses du ségur d'embauché du monde
dès aujourd'hui les soignants continuent
de quitter l'hôpital où il ya beaucoup
aussi de personnels qui sont en arrêt
pour pourquoi vide donc donc c'est
difficile d'aller dans la rue
aujourd'hui mais mais bien sûr qu'on
continue de se battre sur le fond
aujourd'hui vous avez peut-être pas la
réponse à cette question mais ça
concerne combien de personnes justement
qui se trouvent exclus de ce secteur de
la santé est ce que vous avez
connaissance de ce chiffre
non je ne peux pas vous donner de
chiffres ben c'est pas possible
mais beaucoup trop bien sûr après ce
ségur il faut il faut pas se dire que
c'est terminé c'est c'est un début et on
va continuer pour tout le monde c'est
vrai que nous représentons le collectif
interagences aujourd'hui le collectif
s'interroge ans a tendance à vouloir se
s'ouvrir parce que le service des
urgences mais c'est aussi bien de
travailler avec l'amicale que laval donc
on va continuer à se battre pour que ce
soit pas une fin à ce cycle
merci noémie ban présidente du collectif
inter urgence d'avoir été avec nous dans
quelques instants
restez avec nous parlerons de la future
relation entre les etats-unis et la
russie avec l'arrivée de joe biden avait
maison blanche deux pays qui ont
toujours entretenu des relations
délétères et puis direction l'europe
1 le vieux continent est à la manoeuvre
avec de législation peut retrouver sa
souveraineté numérique
[Musique]
le crime est tellement épouvantable que
je pense qu'une partie de l'église mais
comme une partie de la société ne veut
pas le voir de 1950 à aujourd'hui le
travail de la commission a permis
d'identifier trois mille victimes 1500
agresseurs ces chiffres sont forcément
très en deçà de la réalité puisque des
victimes sont décédées des victimes ne
peuvent pas parler peut-être ne
parleront jamais ça montre cette
tragédie qui lie à un système au tour
c'est-à-dire comment des agresseurs
ont-ils pu agresser 10/20 parfois trente
ans nous sommes loin du bout du chemin à
vous savez des institutions se réforment
lentement l'église peut être encore plus
lentement je ne sais pas mais en tout
cas je pense que la prise de conscience
est fait de tels scandales de tels
drames de telles tragédies dans la vie
oblige à la vérité
[Musique]
olivier le revenu universel utopie ou
vraie solution face à la crise le nom
vraie bêtise c'est à dire que vous
dépendrez entièrement de l'état le
problème du revenu et recel c'est
effectivement il y aura une contrepartie
sucera qu'on va supprimer un certain
nombre d' aide c'est extrêmement
dangereux parce que finalement les 9,2
millions de pauvres
on annonce les lits vont être encore
plus haut c'est un espèce de nivellement
par le bas c'est à dire à tout le monde
à 750 euros mais avec 750 euros vous
pouvez vivre les entreprises on
attendait juste plus la peine de payer
2000 euros les gens ils ont déjà d'oise
et son autocollant felipe - là on parle
de 400 milliards pour faire un revenu
universel et 400 milliards 70 % du pib
on fait comment on les sort d'où
[Musique]
où part de l'afrique comme d'un
continuant en perpétuelle 2 son
dysfonctionnement actuel tient à
l'absence de redistribution à la
population par des dirigeants qui ont
une fâcheuse tendance à tout garder pour
les pays occidentaux ont favorisé cette
dérive en encourageant le maintien au
pouvoir de politiciens de plus en plus
âgés pour assurer la stabilité des pays
et des sous régions elles ont eu la
prétention de croire que les valeurs
qu'elle défend des est imposé par la
force dans leur conquête était universel
dans cette terre des possibles
s'esquisse les figures du monde à venir
il faut changer notre logiciel et
arrêtez de dénigrer le faire à
l'africaine en octroyant au management à
l'anglo-saxonne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
20h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus en direct si vous nous
rejoignez joe biden sur le chemin de la
maison blanche sans surprise le collège
électoral a confirmé hier sa victoire à
la présidentielle
le démocrate deviendra officiellement le
46e président des états unis le 20
janvier prochain à joe biden qui n'a pas
caché sa satisfaction appelé les
américains à tourner la page de la
présidence trump et précision avec
hélène masquelier un rituel
constitutionnel d'habitude peut
remarquer les placée cette année sous
les feux de la rampe
les 538 grands électeurs de 50 états se
sont réunis pour voter en faveur de joe
biden ou de donald trump en reflet du
vote populaire
la californie l'état le plus peuplé des
états unis votre a officiellement pour
le vainqueur du vote populaire de notre
état jeff herbes hayden et sa colistière
la californienne kamala harris sans
grand suspens à la fin de la journée joe
biden et kamala harris ont obtenu 3 106
voix contre 232 pour donald trump et
mike pence
mais au delà de la simple formalité le
collège électoral a été érigé ce lundi
en véritable symbole de la force
démocratique du système politique
américain selon joe biden vous savez
dans la bataille pour l'âme de
l'amérique la démocratie l'emporté nous
le peuple avons voté la foi en nos
institutions a tenu l'intégrité de nos
élections a été préservé maintenant il
est temps de tourner la page
comme nous l'avons fait tout au long de
notre histoire de nous rassembler de
guérir comme je les dis au cours de
cette campagne je serai le président de
tous les américains de malte rome de son
côté avait déclaré qu'il quitterait la
maison blanche si jamais le collège
électoral était favorable à joe biden
si le collège électoral élit le
président biden quitterez-vous la maison
blanche n y en a bien sûr que je le
ferais mais vous le savez déjà mais je
pense qu il se passera beaucoup de
choses d'ici au 20 janvier beaucoup de
choses
une fraude massive a été découverte on
dirait un pays du tiers monde
ces dernières semaines
aucun des recours juridiques de donald
trump visant à contester les résultats
du mois de novembre n'a abouti donald
trump est plus que jamais isolée
son ministre de la justice bill barre a
annoncé sa démission hier il avait
déclaré début décembre n'avoir constaté
aucune fraude à une échelle susceptibles
de changer le résultat électoral
fini donc les recomptages selon
plusieurs médias américains celui qui
est encore le locataire de la maison
blanche devra enfin assumer son destin
électoral dernière étape à présent
l'entrée en fonction du nouveau
président des etats-unis qui doit
intervenir le 20 janvier 2021 et vadim
et recrutent in félicite à son tour joe
biden et se dit prêt à une collaboration
le président russe attendait
l'officialisation des résultats pour
saluer la victoire du président
américain élu les précisions de notre
correspondant à moscou antoine frérot
tout vient à point à qui sait attendre
il aura fallu patienter jusqu'au vote
des grands électeurs et donc la
confirmation de la victoire de joe biden
pour que le président russe finissent
par envoyé un télégramme de
félicitations à l'ancien vice-président
de barack obama qui deviendra le 20
janvier prochain
le 46e président des états unis dans un
télégramme bladimir poutine a exprimé
ses souhaits de succès au président élu
et sa confiance que la russie et les
etats-unis qui sont particulièrement
responsable de la sécurité et de la
stabilité mondiale pouvait malgré leurs
divergeances contribuer réellement au
règlement de nombreux problèmes et défis
auxquels le monde est actuellement
confronté le président russe a noté que
dans cet esprit une coopération russo
américaine basée sur des principes
d'égalité et de respect mutuel serait
dans l'intérêt des peuples des deux pays
et de toute la communauté internationale
alors que la plupart des dirigeants
étrangers ont adressé leurs
félicitations dans les jours suivant
l'élection
le président russe avait fait savoir
qu'il comptait attendre
l'officialisation des résultats à savoir
la fin des recours intentés par donald
trump des recours juridiques qui aurait
pu remettre en cause la victoire du
candidat démocrate
voici ce que disait le porte-parole du
kremlin le 9 novembre dernier
nous considérons approprié d'attendre le
bilan officiel des élections
nous vous rappelons que le président
poutine a déclaré à plusieurs reprises
qu'il respectait le choix du peuple
américain quel qu'il soit et qu'il
serait prêt à travailler avec n'importe
quel président élu des etats unis
dans tous les cas nous espérons pouvoir
établir un dialogue avec le prochain
président des états unis d'amérique
élaborée conjointement des moyens pour
normaliser nos relations bilatérales
d'autant plus qu'une partie importante
de ses relations bilatérales ne concerne
pas seulement nos deux peuples mais tous
les peuples du monde entier
moscou a donc pris acte de l'élection de
joe biden et va désormais devoir s'en
accommoder car ce dernier a promis de se
montrer ferme envers la russie accusé
notamment d'ingérence dans le système
électoral américain lors de l'élection
de 2016 les accusations rejetées en bloc
par les autorités russes
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
pierre laurin journaliste et écrivain
bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous le kremlin qui a
donc attendu les résultats officiels
vladimir poutine est l'un des rares pour
ne pas dire le seul peut-être dirigeants
avoir attendu jusque-là faut-il y voir
un message tacite envoyé à joe biden
c'est un message évidemment mais c'est
un message obligatoire il est très clair
que à partir du moment où les grands
électeurs ont voté que le président élu
est définitivement joe biden l'a dit mr
poutine devait le prendre acte et envoyé
son message de félicitations qu'il avait
d'ailleurs promis pour le candidat qui
serait désigné par les grands électeurs
où début du mois de novembre
donc il n'y a pas là réellement de
surprises ce qui est très intéressant
dans le télégramme que vladimir poutine
a envoyé c'est la volonté de collaborer
mais attention collaborer sur des
principes d'égalité de respect mutuel et
ça ce n'est pas forcément sûr que ce
soit la vision que les etats-unis ont de
la russie alors effectivement joe biden
avait
dit lors de l'émission 60 minutes sur
nbc que la russie était le pays le plus
menaçant quelque sorte pour les états
unis avant la chine même est ce qu'on
peut s'attendre tout de même qu'il y ait
une réponse à cette main tendue de la
part de vladimir poutine
il y aura forcément une réponse est
vraisemblablement la réponse ne sera pas
totalement négative c'est à dire qu' il
est de l'intérêt de joe biden de laisser
des portes ouvertes
parce que la situation telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui ne peut pas continuer très
longtemps
on est dans une situation très complexe
au niveau mondial
la russie n'est plus la puissance
d'antan mais c'est une puissance très
importante notamment par sa puissance
nucléaire et les états unis ont tout
intérêt à traiter avec comme disait le
président richard nixon dans l'un de ses
livres
ils ont intérêt à traiter avec la seule
puissance dans le monde capables de les
détruire
actuellement le grand adversaire c'est
la chine mais elle n'a pas encore la
chine la capacité de détruire les états
unis la russie avec son arsenal
nucléaire
le possède donc il y a là un enjeu vital
il est évident qu'une guerre nucléaire
aujourd'hui entre la russie et les etats
unis est impensable
il n'y a pas d'enjeu suffisant pour cela
en revanche il est toujours intéressant
pour les interlocuteurs de garder des
des mesures de négociation des termes de
négociations et là il y a un enjeu
majeur qui se dessine c'est que le
traité d' équilibre nucléaire que l'on
appelle new stats vient qui a été signé
en 2010 vient à son terme en février
or pour le moment rien n'a été négocié
pour sa suite qu'est ce qui va se passer
ensuite
est ce que les traités start vont
s'arrêter là
c'est peu recommandables pour l'
équilibre mondial
est ce que on va propres projets le
traité pendant un temps de négociations
supplémentaires
de toute façon il est très clair qu'il
n'est de l'intérêt de personne
aujourd'hui de s'engager dans une
nouvelle course à l'armement
d'autant plus qu'il ya des armes
nouvelles qui change complètement les
équilibres donc les négociations sont
presque obligatoire est ce qu'elles vont
avoir lieu
ça dépend des états unis puisque la
russie a déjà depuis longtemps déclaré
qu'elle était prête à négocier
en tout cas joe biden de son côté avait
promis avant d'être élu un de se montrer
fermes face à la russie accusé on le
rappelle a notamment d' ingérence
présumée dans le système électoral
américain peut s'attendre à un statu quo
pas de changements notamment dans la
poursuite des sanctions à l'encontre de
la russie
les sanctions à mon avis ne vont pas
changer du moins pas tout de suite il
faudra plusieurs mois voire peut-être
même des années avant que les choses
évoluent en tout cas ce qui est très
clair c'est que les démocrates ont fait
beaucoup de battage en 2016 pour
contester l'élection de donald trump
autour de l'ingérence russe les enquêtes
sur l'ingérence russe à l'intérieur
du système américain n'ont rien donné
elles se sont toutes conclues par
l'absence totale de d'éléments pouvant
prouver une intervention digne de ce nom
de la part de la russie
les liens entre donald trump et la
russie sont tombées à l'eau il n'y a
rien
mais les démocrates ne peuvent pas se
déjuger aujourd'hui sont bien obligés de
dire mais oui il y a eu interférence il
ya eu ingérence russe
donc il continue sur cette voie là
jusqu'au moment où ils diront lorsque
tout cela sera oublié
ils diront oui eh bien on va repartir
d'un nouveau pied on va faire quelque
chose de différent mais de toute manière
la diabolisation de la russie continuera
parce que je crois que c'est dans les
gènes actuelle du système politique
américain il faut qu'il y ait un ennemi
un ennemi pour non pas pour les
etats-unis mais pour le temps si les
américains veulent conserver l'otan il
faut que la russie sur l'ennemi
alors il y a évidemment ce que vous
venez de nous expliquer la géopolitique
les enterrer évidemment supérieur des
nations mais il ya aussi les relations
entre les hommes qui peuvent parfois
arranger bien des choses comment vous
voyez la relation entre l'homme
joe biden et l'homme vladimir poutine si
j'ose dire
c'est très difficile c'est une question
qui est très difficile à
à répondre simplement parce que les
relations entre joe baidhani et que
lorsqu'il était vice-président et
vladimir poutine étaient très correctes
byden est une personnalité est un
véritable homme politique américain il
est copain avec tout le monde
il serre la main tout le monde il sourit
il rit avec tout le monde mais ça c'est
la façade derrière il ya d'autres choses
mais en tout cas les relations étaient
cordiales en revanche il ya un élément
qui est très important dans les
relations aujourd'hui entre vladimir
poutine et joe biden c'est la faire un
tabac iden son fils qui est compromis
dans une affaire de corruption en
ukraine
c'est la fameuse affaire but risma et
les clés de cette affaire sont
évidemment à kiev
mais les américains font le nécessaire
pour étouffer tout ce qui est possible
en revanche il y a beaucoup d'éléments à
moscou et ces éléments de moscou peuvent
surgir à n'importe quel moment et c'est
ça le véritable jeu qui peut se se nouer
entre baden et et poutine est ce que
réellement poutine peut influencer d'une
manière bien entendu en sous main pour
que la sphère byden éclater au grand
jour va faire un tabac y donne
évidemment
ou bien est ce qu'au contraire il va
rester tranquille il va se tait il ne va
rien faire de manière à ne pas
compromettre les futures relations avec
les états unis
c'est vraisemblable c'est
vraisemblablement la deuxième solution
qui sera adoptée mais cela place alors
que vladimir poutine n'avait aucun
aucune influence réelle sur donald trump
il peut avoir une influence dans la
gratte ça cela sur joe biden merci
beaucoup aux pierre laurent genêt
ces écrivains nous avoir apporté votre
éclairage et 10,6 l investiture donc le
20 janvier plusieurs étapes dans le
processus de troncs processus de
transition qui s'annonce délicat à
l'image de cette séquence qui a provoqué
de vives réactions
youtube a expliqué ces derniers jours
vouloir supprimer tout contenu qui
évoque une possible de fraude lors de
l'élection présidentielle la plateforme
de vidéos en ligne justifie son choix
par la lutte contre la désinformation
les explications de thomas bonnin il y
avait eu les signalements de tweets de
donald trump par les modérateurs du
réseau social
les promesses de facebook de combattre
la désinformation voici maintenant la
censure made in youtube la plateforme de
vidéos en ligne qui appartient à google
a annoncé la suppression de 8000 chaîne
et de plusieurs milliers de vidéos
depuis le mois de septembre
il leur est reproché d'avoir proposer du
contenu jugé comme contraire à la
politique de youtube
désormais ce sont toutes les vidéos
affirmant qu'une fraude massive à
modifier l'issue du scrutin présidentiel
américain qui seront retirés
suffisamment d'état ont certifié leurs
résultats électoraux pour déterminer un
président élu pour cette raison nous
commencerons à retirer tout contenu
publié aujourd'hui ou à n'importe quel
moment après qui induit en erreur les
gens en affirmant qu'une fraude massive
ou des erreurs ont modifié l'issue de
l'élection présidentielle américaine de
2020 la plateforme promettent aussi
d'intensifier ses efforts pour dit-elle
lutter contre la désinformation
un procédé qui interpelle beaucoup
estimant qu'il s'agit d'une décision
éditoriale et que de fait il s'agit d'un
parti pris politique youtube répond en
expliquant que les vidéos d'opinion
seront toujours accepté si elles
contiennent suffisamment de contextes
éducatifs documentaire scientifique ou
artistique
toujours est il que le débat fait rage
sous couvert de lutte contre les
contenus malveillants est trompeur
les géants du numérique feurs est il de
la politique c'est ce que pense donald
trump en tout cas le locataire de la
maison blanche régulièrement ciblés par
les campagnes de modération de twitter
notamment souhaite abroger ce qu'on
appelle la section 230
c'est un passage de
législation américaine encadrant
internet ce qui accorde aux plateformes
numériques
une immunité par rapport au contenu de
tiers qu'on petit trouver la bataille
fait rage depuis longtemps entre le
locataire de la maison blanche et les
patrons des réseaux sociaux sur cette
question
prise entre deux feux les gars femmes
sont aussi accusés de laisser fleurir
des thèses jugé complotistes sur leurs
plateformes et paraît pourtant évident
que ces entreprises répondent à un
agenda politique
en témoignent leurs récents agissements
concernant certains médias dont nous
faisons partie car si vous regardez
cette vidéo sur twitter ou youtube
actuellement vous aurez sans doute se
remarquer la mention qui figure en bas
de l'écran concernant le financement de
rt france une mention censé s'appliquer
de façon universelle mais visiblement la
plupart en ont été volontairement
exemptés une preuve supplémentaire de ce
qui est perçu par certains comme une
forme de censure et qui conduit de plus
en plus d'internautes à trouver des
plateformes alternatives pourrait elle
se dit inquiet des intentions de la
commission européenne cette dernière a
présenté aujourd'hui le projet de
législation sur l'économie numérique
les géants du web comme facebook ou
amazon sont accusé d'abuser de leur
position dominante dans les moteurs de
recherche et réseaux sociaux
parmi les mesures de ce nouveau projet
des amendes pouvant aller jusqu'à 10% du
chiffre d'affaires mondial des mesures
de transparence concernant la pub en
ligne ou les algorithmes et la création
d'une institution de régulation au temps
au temps de garde fous visant à limiter
les infractions à la concurrence
margrethe vestage guerre s'est exprimée
écoutez la aujourd'hui le trafic sur
internet et si important que nous avons
besoin de remettre de l'ordre dans ce
cas toutes les entreprises implantées en
europe grandes comme petites doivent se
soumettre à une concurrence juste sur
internet comme dans le monde réel pour
en parler nous sommes avec à ian hamel
larrère docteur en droit spécialiste du
numérique
bonsoir ian hamel larrère le plan de
l'europe donc un pour mettre au pas les
gaffes à une réaction on arrive à un
tournant
enfin est-ce que c'est trop tard trop
tôt le bon timing
moi je pense que c'est un petit peu
opportuniste comme législation
aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'on ait
dépassé sur le plan économique par les
gaffes a qui sont devenus absolument
colossaux en termes de chiffre
d'affaires mais aussi en termes de
services et je suis pas sur moi à titre
personnel qu'on arrive à avoir des
champions européens en renforçant
quelque part la législation je sais pas
si c'est le meilleur levier pour les
concurrencer
en tout cas c'est une technique qui a
déjà été employée avec le rg [ __ ] et
finalement ça n'a pas eu les effets
espérés
et ça va même décourager un certain
nombre d'acteurs européens de naître
donc je sais pas si il faut il faut
toujours faire attention quand on veut
créer des législations spécifiques pour
des secteurs particuliers alors l'idée
de sanctionner avant de constater les
dérives c'est bien de cela qu'il s'agit
est ce qu'on prend le problème dans le
bon sens alors la législation n'est pas
encore prête un les dispositions dont on
parle au niveau européen elles seront
sans doute voté d'ici un an et on est
dans des effets d'annoncés déjà pour
jouer aussi le bras de fer avec
peut-être l'administration maiden qui va
se mettre en place et donc pouvoir
négocier des accords sur le numérique
mais pas que puisque les états unis
regardent aussi leurs gaffes à
aujourd'hui avec circonspection
mais il y a aussi d'autres enjeux
d'autres accords qui pourraient venir
dans la balance et les états unis ont
intérêt à avoir des champions numérique
fort et donc peuvent faire des
concessions aussi sur d'autres points
donc il ya aussi un agenda européen qui
qui pourrait être concomitant à 7 à ces
annonces alors on a vu que les sanctions
étaient sales et jusqu'à 10% du chiffre
d'affaires mondial est ce qu'on peut
imaginer aujourd'hui que ces sanctions
puissent être un jour mises en oeuvre
dans l'art dans la vraie vie
alors aujourd'hui il ya des sanctions de
plus en plus forte qui sont déjà prises
1er gp débats jusqu'à sur le règlement
sur la protection des données
personnelles va jusqu'à 10% des du
chiffre d'affaires mondial des
entreprises
aujourd'hui on la semaine dernière la
cnil a annoncé des sanctions énormes
jusqu'à 80 millions d'euros contre
google et 40 millions contre amazon
donc on est déjà dans des montants qui
sont très loin d'être dérisoire il ya
apple qui s'est fait également
sanctionné récemment par l'irlande pour
enfin sur des questions fiscales et donc
on voit bien aujourd'hui que la
régulation du numérique elles arrivent
les sanctions elles sont déjà là après
est-ce que ça va permettre vraiment
parce que le sujet cacher c'est le
retard pris par l'europe sur le sujet du
numérique sur le développement
plate forme et ça je sais pas si le
résultat va être atteint en tout cas
google a réagi ce soir nous sommes
inquiets a dit l'entreprise que les
propositions formulées par la commission
européenne semble cibler spécifiquement
une poignée d'entreprises un héron que
difficile le développement de nouveaux
produits afin de soutenir les pme en
europe on sent déjà un petit chantage
google at elle raison aucune raison
d'être inquiet alors je sais pas je ne
sais pas si google a des raisons
immédiates d'être inquiet c'est sûr
qu'aujourd'hui les gaffes à google mais
aussi facebook et consorts sont attaqués
de toutes parts ils sont un petit peu le
coupable idéal pour les politiques qui y
voient voilà le responsable de tous les
maux de la société notamment sur les
sujets de liberté d'expression
finalement ça serait toujours la
responsabilité de cette plate forme mais
finalement que fait la justice puisqu'il
ya déjà des règles qui existent
peut-être que si on faisait appliquer
plus souvent les règles déjà existantes
on n'aurait pas besoin d'être de 2,2 de
recourir ensuite aux gaffes à et de leur
demander de devenir les gendarmes à la
place des gendarmes alors on sent
effectivement je désire une forme de
chantage en tout cas de voilà on vous
prévient le développement de nouveaux
produits afin de soutenir les pme en
europe parce qu'il est un vrai danger a
gêné les pme en europe
avec cette initiative ce qui est certain
c'est qu'aujourd'hui pour faire du
commerce en ligne
on doit placer par ces grandes
plateformes on doit passer on doit
référencer son site sur google est donc
aujourd'hui google consent des gros
efforts pour accompagner notamment les
pme sur les usages digitaux pour allait
s'adresser également auprès de tous les
deux tous les internautes de tous les
consommateurs
on l'a vu ces derniers mois on pouvait
même plus rentrer dans un certain nombre
de commerces et donc la planche de salut
pour beaucoup d'entreprises physique
finalement c'est de ceux numérisés c
passer au numérique et donc les grandes
plates formes en conflit ont aussi
accompagné cette transformation cette
transition numérique et c'était
peut-être aussi là le rôle des états que
d'accompagner les les pme aujourd'hui
c'est google et d'autres plateformes qui
assure ce rôle et c'est un rôle de
service public pour moi donc il ya un
il ya un petit problème des genres mais
c'est pas que de la faute des dégâts fin
merci
ian hamel larrère docteur en droit
spécialiste du numérique
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur l'entrée en vigueur
du couvre feu ce soir le conseil
scientifique lui préconise propos
confinent en avant les fêtes de fin
d'année et puis nous parlerons du bon
goût de la sécurité cette concertation
prévue en janvier voulue par emmanuel
macron afin de réformer la police heures
[Musique]
comment choisissez-vous un film un
projet un scénario un réalisateur avant
de choisir en ait choisi ce qui fait le
propre d'un acteur c'est de partager des
sentiments des idées des émotions
vous vous êtes vraiment dans le cinéma
de créateurs d'initiateur je crois que
le cinéma c'est comme la peinture c'est
comme le la littérature ça reste un art
peut-être que maintenant c'est
l'industrie qui gagne mais du coup
peut-être que ce qui va rester c'est que
les films qui seront de plus en plus
fait pour le cinéma et pas sur les
grands réseaux resteront des objets
artistiques
c'était godard qui disait cette chose si
forte quand on regarde la télévision en
baisse les yeux quand on va au cinéma on
lève les yeux
tout est dit
[Musique]
et y'a pas une façon plus une pauvre de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la table
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
sous les libéraux uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes comment ces mecs-là
arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi je
pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose d'inouï
tg les gens ne s'étaient des valeurs de
droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leur enfant
que le droite
il doit éviter les dérives idéologiques
merci de le souligner comment peut-on
reconstituer une sixième république qui
ne soit pas la doublette parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
[Applaudissements]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française
c'était après les attentats du 11
septembre et quand on vient vous voir et
qu'on vous dit écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu valable moi c'est fini pour moi
est ce que ça remet en armes
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du mahler mais
quel est le rapport avec la radiation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maintenant que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
21h soyez les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france pour cette deuxième heure
d'émission tout de suite voici les types
de l'actualité de ce mardi 15 décembre
adieu confinement bonjour couvre-feu il
est entré en vigueur à 20 heures
précises ce soir le conseil scientifique
préconise le ton confinement avant les
fêtes de fin d'année le monde de la
culture lui ne digère pas les trois
semaines supplémentaires de fermeture
les professionnels et syndicats du
secteur ont manifesté leur colère à
paris et dans plusieurs grandes villes
de france aujourd'hui
côté vaccins l'agencé européenne des
médicaments se réunit le 21 décembre sur
le finder bio ntech la loi sur la
sécurité globale annonce d'une
concertation pour des réformes de la
police sans oublier l'engagement de
réécrire l'article 24 l'onu c'est lui
aujourd'hui ces initiatives de la france
sur le territoire en revanche une partie
des forces de l'ordre proches emmanuel
macron de d avoir accusé dans une
récente interview de procéder à des
contrôles au faciès
le syndicat alliance et unsa ont fait
savoir qu'ils ne participeraient pas au
bout de la sécurité prévues en janvier
[Musique]
au nigéria 1 boko haram revendique l
enlèvement des centaines de lycéens
dans un pensionnat le groupe djihadiste
est en discussions avec le gouvernement
de l'état de katsina
les faits se sont déroulés ce week-end
dans le nord ouest du pays en 2014 boko
haram avait enlevé 276 lycéenne à chier
cibox puis en guinée alpha condé prête
serment pour un troisième mandat après
des élections violentes dont
l'opposition a rejeté le résultat
une cérémonie en présence d'une douzaine
de chefs d'état africains et de
représentants de la france de la cedeao
encore des nations unies au président
qui appelle les guinéens oublier le
passé et à se tourner vers un avenir
d'unité et d'espérance promettant de
gouverner autrement
[Musique]
le besoin d'attestation donc pour
circuler en france mais un couvre-feu à
partir de 20 heures dont depuis une
heure et jusqu'à 6 heures du matin il a
démarré ce soir l'hexagone ce dès qu'on
filme et avec prudence à l'approché des
fêtes de fin d'année le conseil
scientifique recommande ainsi l'auto
confinement pendant une semaine à ceux
qui souhaitent les passer en famille un
déconfinement qui ne concerne pas tout
le monde
restaurants bars et cafés restaurants
fermés sans garantie ne redonnerait
ouverture le 20 janvier
c'est ce qu'a annoncé le premier
ministre jean castex ce matin et malgré
cette annonce du premier ministre dont
une rallonge de 30 5 millions d'euros
pour soutenir le secteur de la culture
les professionnels étaient dans la rue
aujourd'hui mobilisation partout en
france
à paris rendez vous était donné à la mi
journée place de la bastille à l'appel
de la cgt spectacle
plusieurs milliers de manifestants se
sont rassemblés
notre reporter mécène chebbi a suivi la
mobilisation parisienne
ils étaient des milliers à s'être donnés
rendez vous ici place de la bastille
pour contester cette décision du
gouvernement de prolonger la fermeture
des musées des cinémas ou encore des
théâtres un rassemblement à l'appel de
plusieurs syndicats notamment la cgt
spectacle beaucoup de rassemblement
aussi partout ailleurs en france comme à
lyon à marseille ou encore à montpellier
il dénonce cette fermeture il en appelle
au gouvernement pour revenir sur cette
décision
ils ont comparé même avec les centres
commerciaux ou encore avec les
transports bondé beaucoup de slogans ici
une manifestation qui s'est faite dans
le calme
je vous propose d'écouter quelques
réactions de ces personnes membres du
monde du spectacle qui ont été
accompagnés et soutenus par certains
politiques on n'est pas comme un
commerce c'est à dire que c'est pas du
jour au lendemain on rouvre les portes
et l'activité reprend et là ça fait dix
mois qu'on est quasiment à l'arrêt la
ministre a exprimé
là le choix de ne pas réunir en disant
que le stop and go était trop difficile
pour nous le stop and go nous le vivons
nous sommes sans arrêt à l'arrêt et avec
des faux départs et on n'arrive pas à
reprendre
il ya des on est face à la troisième
vague d'annulations de spectacle là
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que depuis 1er
confinement c'est à dire depuis presque
11 mois maintenant on est toujours les
derniers servis alors que dans les
salles de spectacle et j'en ai été
témoin au mois de septembre toutes les
précautions sanitaires ont été prises
on compte donc on a fait super attention
il ya eu aucun cluster dans les salles
de spectacle ni dans les salles de
cinéma
et aujourd'hui on est les derniers
servis donc c'est pas normal
d'autant que je pense qu un secteur qui
sert à faire oublier aux gens que les
malheurs qu'on vit quotidiennement
devrait être mis en avant parce que les
problèmes psychologiques
la déprime ça a des impacts sur la santé
terrible et bizarrement ça n'existe plus
une douche froide donc pour le monde de
la culture qui en appelle au
gouvernement pour revenir sur cette
décision de prolonger la fermeture des
lieux culturels certains artistes nous
ont même confié que la situation
devenait délicate beaucoup d'entre eux
sont tombés dans la précarité certains
théâtres avait fermé côté gouvernement
ils sont prêts à réexaminer cette
situation partir de la rentrée 2021 pour
le probable réouverture à partir du 7
janvier prochain une mobilisation qui
intervient au moment où acteurs au
moment où comédiens et puis est
syndicats ont décidé de déposer un
référé liberté
une procédure d'urgence devant la plus
haute juridiction administrative le
conseil d'état pour que le gouvernement
puisse revenir sur cette décision et
c'est donc une nouvelle phase qui
s'ouvre aujourd'hui face aux convives
mais elle est loin d'offrir de loin
d'offrir de nouvelles libertés aux
français ou à certains professionnels
pour parler de cette période avec des
échéances sans certitude nous sommes
avec alexis poulain c'est notre rubrique
l'édito bonsoir alexis poulain merci
d'être avec nous nouvelles règles donc
aujourd'hui on vient d'en parler mais
invitation tout de même à l'auto
confinement y compris les enfants qu'ils
n'iraient pas l'école en tout cas ce
serait mieux nous at-on fait comprendre
sans obligation ans n'est ce pas les
français peuvent-ils y voir clair selon
vous vous avez dit comprendre je crois
que problème c'est là qu'est ce qu'on
comprend de ces mesures finalement qui
sont incompréhensibles
puisque il y a quelques mois jean michel
blanquer disait que les écoles n'était
pas le lieu de contamination que les
enfants n'étaient pas porteurs
finalement n'était pas plus contaminant
que les autres voire moins et puis là on
nous dit que ce serait bien que les
enfants rate l'école un deux jours avant
la fin de la semaine pour être sûrs
qu'ils n'emmènent pas le coc vide dans
les familles mais les professeurs eux en
revanche devrait aller à l'école puisque
jean-michel bancaire se félicite qu'il
n'y ait pas plus de cas de co vite dans
les écoles auriez eu beaucoup de quatre
communes malheureusement au sein des
classes mais aussi au sein du personnel
enseignant et tout ça dans une dans une
impréparation comme d'habitude
finalement puisque c'est lundi soir très
tard que la nouvelle a été annoncée que
l'école n'était plus obligatoire cette
semaine parce qu'ils avaient le combine
et donc les enfants n'étaient pas
obligés d'y aller pour deux jours mais
quelle est la logique finalement avec
tout ce qu'on nous a dit pendant des
mois si on cherche la logique dans les
mesures de confinement de déconfinement
de stop and go comme ça a été dit dans
le reportage bien on ne trouvera pas de
choses évidentes on a l'impression
d'improvisation permanente difficile et
angoissante pour les français alors ça
suscite évidemment de la colère colère
notamment du monde de la culture on l'a
vu aujourd'hui et
et restaurateurs qui ne sont plus sûrs
de rouvrir le 20 janvier à leur grand
désespoir ensemble que la grogne monte
de plus en plus dans le pays oui la
grogne monte de plus en plus et c'est
compréhensible
le secteur de la culture extrêmement
touché par ces confinement à répétition
qui ne comprend pas les mesures qui sont
prises puisque encore une fois les
salles de cinéma les selles tard on
n'était pas des lieux de contamination
n'était pas des clusters a comme on dit
donc pourquoi alors que tout le monde
avait respecté les consignes on décide
de fermer sans avoir de date de
réouverture extrêmement claires les
restaurants qui sont les sacrifiés de
cette politique sanitaire et dont on dit
maintenant que finalement la date de
janvier ne seraient pas forcément sur et
est assuré comment voulez vous préparer
un plan une année un budget quand vous
êtes soumis au bon vouloir d'un conseil
de sécurité d'un conseil de défense qui
va décider d'un mois sur l'autre que
vous avez le droit d'ouvrir quinze jours
ou pas et qu' on ne sera pas comment
tout ça va se passer
les aides elles sont là elles sont
présentes et minimisons pas mais ne
touche pas tout le monde
il ya des gens qui ont ouvert des
commerces des sociétés trop tard pour en
bénéficier
et puis elles ne seront pas suffisantes
l'autorité bancaire européenne vient
d'alerter les banques françaises et
européennes de faillite nombreuses qui
vont arriver en 2021 et d'un risque
systémique de faillite des banques
puisque derrière ces des dettes qui ne
vont pas être payé et on parle de 1700
milliards de dettes privées inde
d'entreprise et d'être privés et là il
n'y a pas de plan on fait de l'argent
magique avec la bce ont fait des aides
de la manière improvisée comme
d'habitude pour le secteur culturel et
autres
mais ce n'est pas suffisant pour sauver
le nombre d'emplois des intermittents le
nombre d'emplois aussi dans la
restauration les emplois aussi étudiants
qui sont nécessaires pour les étudiants
qui sont je le rappelle les jeunes sont
les plus touchés de ses mesures
sanitaires lui de contrôle qu vide et il
se retrouve à faire la queue aux banques
alimentaires ils se retrouvent privés de
revenus par ces petits boulots qu'ils
faisaient avant et qui est leur
permettait de subvenir langues
- aujourd'hui on est en train de
sacrifier les plus jeunes on est en
train de sacrifier des secteurs entiers
sous prétexte de lutter contre un virus
dont le taux de mortalité je le rappelle
n'est quand même pas catastrophique il
touche les plus âgés ils touchent
certaines pathologies des jeunes aussi
il est dangereux ce virus il existe mais
pourquoi autant d'acharnement autant de
difficultés autant de bâtons dans les
roues pour des secteurs économiques qui
ne demande qu'à accueillir du monde et
qu'à travailler et dans ce contexte très
tendu on se demande quelles pourraient
être les conséquences sur une éventuelle
à un deuxième candidature d'emmanuel
maquereau en 2022 même si c'est loin
c'est demain matin finalement pour en
parler à alexis et vont nous faire
réagir je vous propose d'écouter le chef
de l'état un excès intéressant sur lors
de son interview sur le magazine
d'information site d'information et
écouter peut-être que je pourrai pas
être candidat peut-être que je devrais
faire des choses dans la dernière année
dans les derniers mois
dur parce que les circonstances
l'exigeront et qui rendront impossible
le fait que je sois candidat je n'exclus
rien on a vécu des choses qui étaient
absolument imprévisible alors justement
la stratégie du coc vie des restrictions
que nous impose le gouvernement est ce
que ça pourrait faire partie selon vous
de ces choses dures auquel fait
référence
emmanuel macron oui ça pourrait tout à
fait en faire partie c'est des mots qui
sont extrêmement inquiétant parce que ça
voudrait dire qu emmanuel macron est en
train de faire des scénarios sur ce que
seraient les mois à venir
on a vu à plusieurs scénarios sur
déconfinement re confinement avec sans
vaccins avec ou pas deuxième vague avec
une recombinase ation de ce virus
le problème c'est que qu'est ce que ça
veut dire des choses dures on a vu des
choses dures de ce gouvernement la façon
dont ont été traités les manifestants
lors des actes des dirigeantes de même
le week-end dernier le nombre
d'arrestations abusives qui ont été
constatés par les associations des
droits de l'homme mais aussi simplement
par la justice qui a libéré les gens
arrêtés qui n'étaient pas des black
blocs qui n'étaient pas des séditieux
qui n'étaient pas des gens qui étaient
là pour mettre en danger la république
mais simplement arrêter parce qu'ils
étaient là en train de manifester
donc une attaque manifeste au droit de
manifester ça c'est dangereux
inquiétant ces mots là finalement ils
sont beaux à tiroirs qu'est ce que c'est
que des choses dures est-ce que c'est
davantage encore
liberticides comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui des lois de censure sur les
réseaux sociaux des lois de censure
aussi sur la liberté d'expression la
liberté de l'express tout ça qui a été
montré du doigt par les instances
internationales
est-ce que c'est davantage de mesures
sanitaires qui vont être là aussi
liberticide
quoi qu'il en soit des mots dans la
bouche d'un président en disant qu'il va
être obligé de faire des choses dures
potentiellement l'année où ils seraient
capables de se représenter ne disent
qu'une chose c'est que emmanuel macron
est prêt à aller jusqu'au bout
or quand il a été élu en 2017 il a été
élu comme le réformateur ce président
qui devait faire les réformes
systémiques changer la france
la moderniser c'était son discours
depuis 2010 est son bilan est
extrêmement maigre et c'était bien avant
le coc vide
il n'a fait que très peu de réformes et
la grande réforme celle des retraites
elle est à l'arrêt clairement elle
n'arrivera pas avant 2022
richard ferrand parle même d'un deuxième
quinquennat sur le ton de la blague
peut-être mais en disant qu'il faudra
deuxième quinquennat pour faire la
réforme des retraites parce que pour ce
premier quinquennat
les réformes sont à l'arrêt et même les
réformes avant coville n'ont pas eu lieu
donc emmanuel macron a vendu a survendu
c'était cette image de la start up née
schott du président jeunes du maine
nouveau et on se rend compte qu'il
continue une politique à la françois
hollande où rien ne se passe ou
finalement
eh bien il fait semblant mais il ne se
passe rien si ce n'est de la répression
davantage de lois liberticides et moins
de liberté d'expression c'est inquiétant
je crois qu'il faut que nous soyons
conscients des dangers qui sont devant
nous et que ce virus ne peut pas tout
excuser
loin de là et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui dans la rue que vous
aviez à la fois le monde du spectacle
monde de la restauration et les gens qui
luttent pour défendre nos libertés qui
sont présents et qui sont présents
encore tous les week-ends le risque
c'est en 2021
beaucoup de faillites est davantage de
monde dans la rue parce que aujourd'hui
les instances représentatives que sont
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat sont
faibles et que les contre-pouvoirs sont
faibles et donc les français préfèrent
être dans la rue pour faire valoir leurs
droits c'est grave et j'espère qu'en
2022 mails mac os x se présenter et
qu'il n'aura pas à prendre des décisions
ou dur merci alexis poulain pour cet
édito mersen et est la veille d'un débat
dans l'hémicycle autour de la stratégie
vaccinale les députés de différents
bords demande la transparence et de la
confiance qu'on est il du côté du
gouvernement éléments de réponse avec
lille à saraf le gouvernement doit
présenter sa stratégie ce mercredi à
l'assemblée nationale
et le lendemain au sénat une
intervention suivie d'un débat sans vote
emmanuel macron a déjà tenté de rassurer
d'abord il ya une stratégie qui repose
sur plusieurs vaccins calmants une
stratégie qui va être d'abord de sortir
de manière organisée du confinement en
fonction de résultats
ensuite compte quand on aura
suffisamment peu de cas par jour réussir
à mieux les suivre et nous organiser
avec tester alerté protégé qui au fond
l'idée de dire on se fie beaucoup mieux
beaucoup plus finement et on porte la
contrainte non pas sur toute la nation
mais sur celles et ceux qui sont
infectés lors qu'à contacter ce qui est
une autre stratégie et qui est très
importante en continuant à protéger nos
anciens et ont fait monter la stratégie
vaccinale
même son cloche du côté d'olivier véran
qui se livre néanmoins davantage le
ministre de la santé a esquissé les
trois phases de la future campagne de
vaccination
d'abord dans les ehpad début janvier
puis entre février et mars pour les
personnes présentant des facteurs de
risque ou les professionnels de santé
puis la campagne grand public à partir
du printemps
le laboratoire sanofi a lui annoncé que
son vaccin ne serait pas prêt avant la
fin 2021
la france comptait pourtant sur ces
doses pour sa deuxième phase de
vaccination le printemps prochain
cette question est sur toutes les lèvres
faut-il s'en inquiéter
on ne sait pas tout évidemment sur les
premiers vaccins qui arrive mais on dira
ce qu'on sait ce qu'on ne sait pas ayant
ensuite une haute autorité de santé qui
sur la base des autorisations de grandes
agences agences américaines l agence
européenne fait des recommandations donc
faut pas non plus laisser penser que ce
sont juste les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques moi je suis très attaché
à ce que l'information en la matière
elles soient tenus par des organismes
publics indépendants en particulier le
mba au niveau européen
que la stratégie vaccinale elles soient
dictées par justement une institution
indépendante qu'est la hs et qu'elles
soient déclinées sous le contrôle d'une
expertise et sa transparence comme les
politiques de l'opposition les français
restent sceptiques
selon un sondage de l'agencé sanitaire
santé publique france seule la moitié
interrogeant novembre veut se faire
vacciner contre deux tiers en juillet
le bobo de la sécurité se fera sans les
syndicats alliance et unsa une partie
des forces de l'ordre proches à emmanuel
macron de les avoir accusées dans une
récente interview de procéder à des
contrôles au faciès
très remontés les deux syndicats
demandent le soutien inconditionnel du
premier ministre et du président alors
alliance cherche-t-il à faire pression
c'est l'objet de notre face à face et
pour en débattre nous sommes avec david
biraud porte-parole jeunesse de la
france insoumise bonsoir david guiraud
merci d'être avec nous à vos côtés
yannick biancheri secrétaire
départemental alliance police 38
bonsoir à vous aussi merci d'être là
alors c'est votre syndicat et [ __ ]
biancheri qui a donc poussé un coup de
gueule ce matin après les propos du
président sur les contrôles au faciès
pas question de se rendre au bureau de
la sécurité en janvier alliance demande
le soutien inconditionnel du
gouvernement l'heure est grave
la rupture est consommée oui leur grève
qu'on ne peut pas être président de
république et avoir de tels propos on
peut pas être président d'ad lui que
reconnaître des contrôles au faciès
on ne peut pas être président de la
république et reconnaître qu' il ya des
violences policières tout ça pour faire
plaisir à un média brut
donc on ne répond pas comme ça en disant
si vous voulez oui il ya des violences
policières
donc tout n'est pas blanc tout n'est pas
noir mais un des propos comme ça
viennent se rajouter à tous l'abattage
médiatique qu'il ya eu depuis certains
mois certaines années et bien sûr qu'une
vocation que mes collègues rentrent par
vocation de la police mais elle est
belle successivement ces vagues
une vielle à éroder le gros rocher qui
est la vocation est maintenant mes
collègues sont exaspérés n'en peuvent
plus et bien sûr ne vous souhaite pas
que ce mauvais au ce2 beauvau de la
sécurité se tienne si on n'a pas eu des
gestes ou des actes forts d'un président
de république
yannick est bien que les portes d'un
qu'on comprenne avant de donner parole
évidemment à david guiraud pour vous
c'est quoi c'est un malentendu avec le
chef de l'état c'est de la mauvaise
volonté de sa part tout simplement un
manque de considération caractérisée
comment vous expliquer les choses un
petit problème de liaison avec yannick
biancheri qui semble répondre mais mais
mais sans le son david guiraud vous les
comprenez tout de même ces policiers on
nous a voilà de temps en temps pour pour
évoquer ce thème parfois vous avez des
mots durs par contre la police mais
voilà on parle souvent de violences
policières présumées avec vous est ce
que là sur ce coup là c'est j'ose dire
vous les comprenez un petit peu mais moi
j'ai aucun problème pour discuter avec
les policiers c'est pas ça la question
mais ce que fait alliance police
aujourd'hui ça ne m'étonne pas pascal
alliance police est systématiquement du
côté du silence et de la négation du
réel quand un producteur de musique se
fait tabasser michel est clair par par
la police par des policiers alliance
police ne défend pas les la personne
agressée elle ne défend pas le français
qui se fait agresser
elle défend les policiers en ouvrant une
cagnotte de solidarité avec les agrée
pour les agresseurs de michel est clair
qu'en également la police un policier le
brigadier chef amar ben mohamed soulève
et lance la leyre tu as inscrit un
système de maltraitance racistes au sein
du tribunal de grande instance de paris
alliance police j'ai d'ailleurs un de
ces tracts ne défend pas ne sort pas un
tract pour de se mobiliser contre le
racisme dans la société ou même au sein
de la police ils font un tract oui ils
le montrent je vous le montre a bien
marqué alliance police 75 dénonce le
brigadier-chef ben amar ben mohamed
voilà donc ça c'est un autre position
des journalistes font leur travail et
pour leur travail honnêtement je pense à
ta aboaf voyez ils sont comparés à des
chiens donc ça c'est une image de chiens
qui qui qui est la représentation d'un
journaliste français
je pourrais continuer longtemps mais moi
j'ai peur qu'on vivre
deux mondes différents pour être honnête
parce que moi aujourd'hui je n'étais pas
sur la grogne par rapport à ce que dit
une phrase d'un président dans brut
j'étais à un tribunal avec eric coquerel
en soutien à la famille de gaye camara
qui a été abattu d'une balle dans la
tête par la bac
il y à il ya de ça quelques quelques
années de la même manière que à grenoble
à bac de grenoble moi je veux bien qu'on
en parle il ya adam et faty qui sont
deux jeunes qui ont été tués parce que
la paix la bac de grenoble s'est entêté
dans une course poursuite qui a causé la
mort de ces deux ces deux jeunes gens
voyez gaye camara a dans les fatigues il
n'avait pas pu déposer des lettres de
démission il n'avait pas eu le choix
voilà ils sont morts mais je préfère
rassurer les policiers de la bac
nous procéderons si nous sommes au
pouvoir à une dissolution de la batture
a pas besoin de mettre des lettres de
démission et nous prendrons avec nous
les policiers qui se lève le matin pour
défendre les français
pas pour les agresser mais je constate
aujourd'hui alliance police nationale et
du côté et syndics des gens violents et
les défend donc a priori effectivement
bas nous acceptons vos lettres de
démission si jamais on était au pouvoir
nous le débat c'est un petit peu étendu
et yannick biancheri il a le mérite en
tout cas de s'ouvrir ce débat alors je
rappelle que l'alliance police n'est pas
seul à ne pas vouloir participer à ce
beauvau il ya aussi une star vous
répondez quoi vous aurez yannick
biancheri à david guiraud
la première chose c'est que je suis
d'accord de lui on ne vise clairement
pas dans le même monde
monsieur guiraud dû être bloquée dans un
monde de bisounours monsieur guy roux se
sert d'exemple pour faire une vendetta
contre la police nationale monsieur
guiraud ne reconnaît pas le travail au
quotidien le figaro je parle vous
répondrai après monsieur gayraud ne
reconnaît pas tant que commissaire à
l'éthique est ce important vous êtes
habitué des plateaux et je pense que
vous pouvez apprendre à faire du
dialogue c'est à dire écoutez aime pas
seulement que parler donc monsieur dire
oh je ne vis pas que j'aurais fait
monsieur gayraud ne vit pas clairement
dans le même monde que moi parce que il
ne se rend pas compte l'avis de mes
collègues au quotidien leur dur travail
donc l'alliance police nationale parce
qu'on est attaquée directement avec
internationale ne défend pas tout et
n'importe quoi par contre défendre la
présomption d'innocence je sache je suis
pas juge vous n'êtes pas juge monsieur
guiraud n'est pas juger les médias non
plus on ne juge pas une affaire sur une
bribe d'image
donc oui
portiragnes et nationales qui font
qu'elle ne servirait à rien il ya une
différence monsieur biancheri
reconnaissez-le quand même vous
reconnaissez peut-être aussi qu' il ya
deux poids deux mesures quand on juge
les affaires du point de vue médiatique
tant il ya encore il ya quelques mois en
arrière on a un collègue qui a été tuée
dans un accident de la route percuté par
une femme ivre au volant avec le
cannabis dans le sang sans permis de
conduire et qu'au bout de trois semaines
elle est libérée de prison
est ce que vous croyez pas qu'il ya
peut-être deux poids deux mesures entre
juger une affaire sur une bribe d'image
et incarcéré mes collègues et que
peut-être mes collègues ne passeront pas
noël a d'ailleurs animé si je vous
réponds alors laissez-moi vous répondre
sur ça puisque non mais ayons un et l'on
ait un dialogue non mais vous voulez
avoir un dialogue ayant un dialogue a
pas de y'a pas de soucis moi je vais
vous dire une chose je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la police nationale comme
à peu près tous les tous les corps de la
fonction publique aujourd'hui est
victime d'une maladie d'une maladie qui
s'appelle la course aux chiffres d'une
maladie qui s'appelle le la dénégation
parfois aussi de systèmes qui sont à
part de violence de la négation du fait
qu'il y ait du racisme comme partout
dans la société mais que aujourd'hui les
policiers raciste et violent entraîne
souvent dans leur logique d'autres
policiers évidemment moi je veux bien
reconnaître et je ne vous le cache pas
le quotidien des policiers français est
très dur quand j'entends des gens qui
disent suicidez vous à des policiers je
suis choqué et je pense que ça choque
énormément de policiers voient là et je
le comprends mais si vous voulez je
pense que le problème d'alliance police
nationale aujourd'hui c'est qu'elle
défend le déni elle ne veut pas que les
changes chose moi je veux que les choses
changent
moi je veux que les choses changent je
pense que les policiers effectivement
beaucoup dans ce pays se lève le matin
en se disant bah je vais défendre les
français je vais protéger la population
malheureusement aujourd'hui ce qui se
passe dans votre syndicat c'est que vous
indiquez des gens violents notamment
ceux qui ont tabassé michel est clair
c'était des membres de votre syndicat et
que entre respecter la présomption
d'innocence
ce que je peux comprendre quand bien
même les images sont assez accablantes
élevé une cagnotte de solidarité pour
des gens qui ont agressé un individu
c'est quand même un peu différent et
aujourd'hui vous êtes dans cette
situation là de soutenir
systématiquement et lorsque vous avez
vos propres collègues comme amar ben
mohamed qui lance l alerte c'est un de
vos collègues c'est même pas un citoyen
vous dénoncez pas le racisme mais le
collègue et c'est une position qui est
systématique chez vous et que je
critique parce que je pense qu elle
n'améliorera pas le quotidien des
policiers
moi je suis pour qu'on mène une
commission denquête c'est la position de
la france est soumise sur par exemple
les suicides dans
la police parce qu'effectivement c'est
un problème pourquoi est-ce qu'il ya
autant de policiers qui se suicide
pourquoi est ce que les conditions de
travail sont aussi désastreuse pourquoi
est-ce que le parc matériel est aussi
dégradée pourquoi est ce que les
commissariats sont dans un état aussi
d'un mental je suis ouvert à tout mais
contre le racisme je ne suis pas ouvert
ni envers les racistes ni envers ceux
qui les défendent les kids f des
cagnottes de solidarité pour eux elle
est un petit peu au-delà du délà des bas
mais c'est intéressant parce que c'est
finalement un débat de fond je vous
propose d'écouter réécouter la phrase du
président qui a mis le feu aux poudres
interview réalisée le 4 décembre dans
laquelle emmanuel macron reconnaît les
contrôles au faciès
écoutez c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui quand
on a une couleur de peau qui n'est pas
blanche on est beaucoup plus contrôler
beaucoup plus et encore plus quand on
est d'ailleurs souvent un garçon parce
que on est identifié comme étant un
facteur de risque de problème est que
c'est insoutenable
yannick biancheri c'est cette petite
phrase emmanuel macron qui vous a heurté
celle qui vous a poussée avec 180
policiers de l'isère a demandé une
rupture conventionnelle à poser votre
démission tout simplement sans cette
phrase ça irait mieux
oui et puis les violences policières
mais moi je tiens à répondre au
président et à monsieur guiraud qui fait
d'un cas une généralité
non mes collègues ne sont pas racistes
il n'y a pas de racisme de la police des
polices nationales système systémique
que je sache pas en parle des contrôles
au faciès
ce n'est pas la police nationale qui
identifie ou qui définit l'image de la
délinquance
quand mes collègues contrôle à 90% c'est
parce qu'il ya une description qui a été
fait d'auteurs d'infractions de crime ou
de délit
donc on ne fait qu contrôler des
personnes qui correspond à 2 des
hauteurs de d'auteurs de crimes
d'effraction ou de délit
quand on nous demande d'intervenir à 80%
de l'eau mais laissez moi parler merci
quand on interrompt de nomades de
d'intervenir à 80 % de notre temps dans
des quartiers ce n'est pas la police
nationale qui a fait la ghettoïsation de
ces quartiers donc voilà faut prendre un
petit peu de la hauteur le président
aurait dû prendre de la hauteur donc et
donc ne pas cautionner le dire que il y
à des concerts off anciens au faciès
david guiraud
mais moi je l ai dit allez-y répondait
oui la police nationale moi je suis
d'accord allez pas responsable de la
ghettoïsation de la société ça non je ne
suis pas contre ça c'est un fait mais
c'est aussi un fait qu'aujourd'hui par
exemple quand vous êtes aux abords d'une
gare vous avez des contrôles sur des
personnes jugées noah au rap c'est le
défenseur des droits qui le dis c'est
pas moi le défenseur des droits estime
que quand vous êtes noir par exemple
vous allez huit fois plus de chance de
vous faire contrôler et ses contrôles là
vous le savez les contrôles d'identité
donne très rarement lieu à une suite
c'est ça le problème aujourd'hui en
france c'est qu'on mène des opérations
de police et on embarque les policiers
là dedans parce que c'est vrai que c'est
des consignes qui leur sont données de
contrôle et moi je peux l'entendre c'est
des consignes qui sont données
c'est de la course aux chiffres de la
politique du chiffre d'aller contrôler
des gens d'aller faire la traque aux
gens qui ont leur petite consomation de
chiites alors qu'on pourrait peut-être
se dire que la police pour être employés
pour démanteler des grands réseaux par
exemple de stupéfiants et trafic en ski
de trafic de drogue ce qui n'est que
très peu fait aujourd'hui moi je veux
bien dire mais par contre
reconnaissez se fait là quand vous êtes
aux abords d'une gare et qui a eu beau
il ya huit fois plus de chances d'être
contrôlé quand on est noir ou arabe sans
aucun délit commis parce que c'est pas
vrai qu'il ya des délits commis parce
que la plupart des contrôles d'identité
ne donne pas lieu ne donne pas lieu à
autre chose que le contrôle d'identité
et quand ils donnent lieu à quelque
chose c'est souvent des outrages
d'ailleurs la cncdh la commission
nationale des droits de l'homme pas non
plus une officine marxiste léniniste 1
eh ben la cncdh nous dit que les
contrôles d'identité sont devenus et
c'est une citation un abcès de fixation
de tensions entre la police et la
population ce que j'essaye de dire c'est
qu'il y à des policiers qui sont
racistes c'est vrai il ya des ordres qui
sont données qui ne sont pas corrects et
qui met les policiers dans des
situations difficiles
c'est vrai aussi mais il ya aussi et moi
je il faut aussi se dire quand un
policier fait quelque chose qui n'est
pas bien je pense à ce qui s'est passé
pour monsieur est clair c'est à dire il
entraîne dans sa maison nabil bureau et
je fais des heures aujourd'hui ne
réagissent pas je suis ni très
rapidement dans vos comics ans michel
est clair se fait tabasser au sol il ya
aucun des onze policiers ou des douze
policiers sur place qui se dit qu'il va
dire à son collègue d' arrêter de te
frapper au visage un homme au sol et ça
c'est pas normal
merci en tout cas à tous les deux david
guiraud yannick biancheri d'avoir été
avec nous pour échanger dont sur le bobo
de la sécurité sachant que votre
syndicat david biancheri alliance police
ne veut pas y participer ainsi que vos
collègues du nca merci à tous les deux
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france va poursuivre avec le
développement de l'actualité sur le
continent africain cette fois au nigeria
le gouverneur de l'état de katsina
annonce que des discussions sont en
cours avec boko haram le compte des
listes a revendiqué l'enlèvement ce week
end on peut de plusieurs centaines
d'élèves dans un pensionnat en 2014 boko
haram avait déjà enlevé 276 me cnh ebook
grazailles avec walid ben ali c'est par
la voix du leader du groupe djihadiste
boko haram que l'enlèvement a été
revendiqué
je suis abubakar shekau et nos frères
sont derrière l'enlèvement de katsina
c'est ce même chef qui avait soulevé une
vague d'indignation mondiale après
l'enlèvement de 276 lycéenne acquis boc
en avril 2014
ce vendredi ce sont plus de 330 élèves
de l'école de garçons de cons kara qui
ont été victimes d'un rapt organisé une
centaine d'assaillants ont fait
irruption à moto
une fusillade a éclaté avec les forces
de sécurité
plusieurs centaines d'élèves ont pris la
fuite dans une forêt environnante et une
partie d'entre eux a été enlevé le
gouverneur de l'état a immédiatement
réagi nous ferons tout ce qui est en
notre pouvoir pour retrouver les enfants
enlevés
un événement qui fait enfler les
critiques contre le président moi ma
double voirie qui se trouvait à 200
kilomètres des lieux on dans son fief
si le chef d'état a condamné l' attaque
la qualifiant d' être menée par des
lâches envers des innocents il ne s'est
pas pour autant rendu sur les lieux du
drame
ce mois ci les attaques se sont succédé
dans le pays
samedi ce sont 27 villageois qui ont été
tués dans la région de diffa ville
située de l'autre côté de la frontière
avec le niger
la population de la région se sont
aujourd'hui totalement abandonnée nous
sommes fatigués d'être déplacés nous
avons des problèmes nous sommes en
difficulté nous sommes préoccupés par la
fin il n'ya pas d'agriculture pour notre
peuple
pas de commerce nous ne pouvons rien
faire face à cette inaction
le parti démocratique populaire a
demandé l'ouverture d'une procédure de
destitution du président cet enlèvement
dans l'état d'origine du président
illustre sa faillite sécuritaire alors
qu'il s'est fait élire sur la promesse
de garantir la sécurité à toutes et à
tous alors que les enlèvements devienne
l'une des industries les plus lucratives
au nigeria
le conflit avec les djihadistes a déjà
fait au moins 36 mille morts depuis 2009
à l'heure actuelle plus de deux millions
de personnes ne peuvent toujours pas
regagné leurs foyers
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis niamey avec moussa aksar
journaliste d'investigation c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir moussa aksar merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france le
président nigérien mahamadou boiré qui
avait donc fait de la sécurité la lutte
contre boko haram sa priorité lors de
son élection en 2015 et pourtant ces
attaques et ces événements qui se sont
multipliés peut-on parler d'échec
aujourd'hui absolument on peut parler
d'échec de la politique sécuritaire de
mamadou barry depuis qu'il est arrivé au
pouvoir
parce que comme vous le savez il a dit
qu'il va faire de la lutte contre les
groupes djihadistes qui s'est dit dans
cette partie nord du nigeria sa priorité
aujourd'hui après son premier manga et
le second on constate qu'il a et la
banque a également échoué avec toutes
ces attaques
avec tous ces enlèvements des centaines
d élèves ont été tout à l'heure dans la
vie dans le reportage on était à l'idée
et même chez lui non loin de chez lui ça
prouve que sa politique sécuritaire a
failli comment vous l'expliquez vous cet
échec une question de moyens de volonté
oui c'est plutôt une question d'
approche parce que comme vous le savez
cette partie du nigeria étaient des
lycées il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'infrastructures il n'y a pas beaucoup
de points d'eau il n'y a pas et des
infrastructures sanitaires ils étaient
délaissées comme ce qu'on a vu au nord
du burkina au nord du mali et tout c'est
toute cette partie el et il n'y a pas la
présence de l'état ce qui prouve que les
groupes jihadistes ont remplacé l'état
et aujourd'hui on récolte le nigeria
récoltes sont en conséquence du fait
qu'il n'a pas placé et qui n'a pas su
mettre des hommes dans cette dans cette
partie là pour qu'il puisse au moins
assurer la sécurité de ces personnes
peut-on imaginer que la présence de
militaires français au niger pousse des
terroristes à se déplacer justement dans
d'autres régions
désertique non pas du tout qu'on vous
les savez aujourd'hui sur les gardes le
mode opératoire de shekau de saison
malgré leur cession ils ont attaqué un
état qui est proche de la frontière
nigérienne
ce pour faire une jonction avec certains
groupes qui sévissent le long de la
frontière nigérienne notamment la zone
de maladie et pour qu'il puisse faire
jonction est porté de coups et faire et
est plutôt mené de combat le long de
cette frontière là et avant les fêtes de
fin d'année pour dire qu'ils existent
bel et bien et qu'ils peuvent attaquer
n'importe où et n'importe quoi alors
effectivement la semaine dernière en 60
oui vous via les i pardonnez moi en ce
qui concerne la foire sarbacane et comme
vous le savez et berkane sookie plus
notamment de la frontière malienne les
trois frontière entre le mali niger et
le burkina
mais la force marque en n'est pas aussi
projetés vers cette frontière nigériane
surtout dans cette partie où il ya eu
cette allemagne plutôt d'aller du
laziale si vous regardez c'est vers le
lit du lac tchad qui a eu beaucoup qui a
beaucoup d'affrontements entre les
groupes terroristes et les forces de
défense et de sécurité des trois pays
notamment le tchad le niger et le
nigeria c'est vrai que cette fin d'année
particulièrement meurtrière en pour le
nigeria la semaine dernière encore 76
permis ont été tuées par le même groupe
terroriste boko haram
aujourd'hui quelles seraient les
solutions d'urgence pour sortir de cette
spirale violente
les solutions c'est le développement il
faudrait nécessairement que ces étapes
ans à développer ces gens là qui ont été
délaissées mais aussi et à mener des
actions surtout de renseignement parce
que le renseignement a failli et vous
avez vu il n'ya pas la présence de
l'état il n'ya pas l'école il ya pas d
infrastructures sanitaires
c'est le groupe djihadiste aujourd'hui
qui font la loi au tour de tout c'est
toute cette bande là toute cette
frontière l'acquis et qui est très vaste
est ce pour cela qu'il faudrait que ces
états là qu'on semblait le foie
les deux liens que l'armement la force
militaire ne peut pas apporter des
solutions dans cette zone là il faudrait
jouer entre le 2 et la force militaire
et les actions de développement et
stabiliser des zones qui sont déjà
acquises vous à ces cas là avant de
poursuivre les actions militaires alors
une dernière question sur cette prise
d'otage ans selon le gouverneur de la
région le gouvernement serait en
pourparlers avec les terroristes quelles
sont les chances de libérer ces
étudiants est ce qu'on évoque le
paiement d'une rançon par exemple wahid
et des chansons mais ce parce que si
vous l'avez suivi tout à l'heure c'est
que et le groupe chico a déjà et
revendiquer c'est cette prise d'otage
mais il ne parle pas des négociations et
c'est serré très difficile pour le
gouvernement nigérian de négocier et la
libération de ces otages
résultat ils vont les enrôler dans des
actions de du tourisme notamment
proposer des ombres de bon goût des
huées des mercis moussa aksar
journaliste d'investigation merci
d'avoir été dans vu de l'extérieur ce
soir et c'est dans un climat tendu
qu'alpha condé apprennent et a prêté
serment donné devant la cour
constitutionnelle un troisième mandat
controversé l'opposition contestent sa
réélection
la cérémonie d'investiture s'est
déroulée en présence d'une douzaine de
chefs d'état africains ainsi que des
représentants de la france de la cedeao
ou encore des nations unies david
khalifa alpha condé
président de la république est libre
conforme à la constitution
vigile devant le peuple de guinée et sur
l'honneur de respecter et de faire
respecter stylistes de demain des
dispositions de la constitution pour la
troisième fois alpha condé 82 ans prête
serment devant la cour constitutionnelle
un nouveau mandat controversée à la tête
de la guinée
en cause une constitution adoptée lors
d'un référendum critiquée en mars
permettant alpha condé de remettre son
compteur présidentielle à 0 pour pouvoir
se représenter
une candidature qui a donné lieu à des
mois de manifestations durement
réprimées et des violences qui ont fait
des dizaines de morts civils depuis
octobre 2019
[Applaudissements]
après la proclamation de la victoire
d'alpha condé au premier tour par la
cour constitutionnelle le 7 novembre
l'opposition dénonce une fraude elle a
une nouvelle fois appelé à manifester ce
mardi alors que l'investiture du
président se déroule sous le contrôle
d'un dispositif de sécurité très
importants policiers gendarmes et
militaires ont été déployés dès le début
de la matinée jusque dans la grande
banlieue de conakry pour éviter tout
débordement
alpha condé de son côté en appel à
l'unité des je crois profondément aux
vertus du dialogue et de la concertation
et j'ai acquis et puis longtemps la
commission que la guinée se fera avec
tous les guinéens
mais chacun doit respecter la loi et
barry de ses propos et des seat la
violence afin que notre pays
demers et ne se soucier des libertés et
de responsabilité un message rempli
d'espoir
reste à savoir si les guinéens seront de
cet avis et pour en parler nous sommes
avec régis ou paix journaliste
d'investigation consultant international
la bonsoir merci d'être avec nous alors
alpha condé qui appelle les guinéens
oublier le passé dans le même temps
plusieurs ong accusent les forces de
sécurité d'être responsable de la mort
de dizaines de manifestants dans quel
contexte s'ouvre selon mon mandat j'ai
compté ce qui est très délicat équipe où
tout vous dire je pensais sujet très
bien qui sera bientôt bientôt fuji à
multiples petites tensions
supplémentaires le le contexte
aujourd'hui si vous voulez
ce sera compliqué pour le président
alpha condé justement parce que
l'opposition les syndicats les jugent
réalistes et s'ils voulaient non pas un
corps justement avec cette élection
aujourd'hui vous avez et celles faites
est dénoncée par amnesty international
human rights
il ya environ enfin s'il n'y a plus de
quatre-vingt cinq manifestants ont été
tués il ya plus de 300 manifestants
aujourd'hui qui sont en prison donc si
vous voulez le président alpha condé
prendront le pouvoir donc pour un
troisième mandat dans des conditions qui
sont extrêmement difficile extrêmement
compliqué pour lui
et cela pour vous dire clairement pour à
la fois pour les guinéens et qui sonne
la dire que moi ou de l'intérieur ne
présage pour u2 rien de bon alors une
dizaine de chefs d'état africains et de
représentants de la france de la cedeao
encore des nations unies sont présents
c'est une reconnaissance internationale
de bon augure selon vous pour le
président alpha condé je pense que c'est
aussi une façon pour lui de récupérer si
vous voulez la légitimité qui n'a pas pu
avoir de façon pas par le peuple donc
c'est une façon de récupérer cette léger
de cette façon pour lui donc de de
chercher par l'international qu'elle
diplomatique dans ces grands africains
diplomatique internationale qui pourrait
légitimer un pouvoir juste moi si vous
voulez qui au niveau national au niveau
populaire a perdu tout son intérêt
aujourd'hui tous les guinéens et pour
l'ensemble des syndicalistes des
opposants alpha condé aujourd'hui n'a
pas droit de cité n'aime pas le
président officiel donc grâce à la
cedeao ou grâce à la france et grâce au
président africain qui était qui était
donc à cette investiture
alpha condé j savoir se servira donc de
cette légitimité de cette quête
diplomatiques pour asseoir son pouvoir
alors légitimité dont il aura bien
besoin parce que en attendant il ya eu
de nouvelles manifestations de
l'opposition aujourd'hui opposition qui
réclame la justice et la colère ne
semble pas retombée comment unifier le
pays dans ces conditions il ya une
propos qui est très intéressant qui a
été rappelé par le président alpha condé
qui appelle donc à l'unité qui a appelé
à la concorde entre les légumes
les guinéens mais pour l'opposition il
ya des choses comme quelqu'un qui est
certaine il faut qu'il y ait une
concorde avant qu'il y ait une
concertation
il faut justement remettre si vous
voulez la balle à terre et la balle à
terre constitue ce mois à un record
convoqué certainement des états généraux
de la gouvernance a convoqué six mois si
vous aussi vous voulez de nouvelles
concertations au jour d'aujourd'hui je
pense qu'il est très compliqué pour le
président guinéen est appelé à l'unité
quand on sait que le pays a été
totalement désunis cas des opposants qui
sont en prison et que si ce moment le
principal son principal challenger
cellou dalein diallo qui estime que
c'est lui qui a remporté les élections m
cruellement mais la fée est à la fois
par des manifestants qui sont proches du
pouvoir ou pas la police du bois alors
alpha condé qui appelle à louverné
pourtant autrement
qu'est ce que cela peut induire comme
changement est ce que c'était tout
simplement à slogan de campagne
je pense clairement csc certains
relèvent davantage plus de la
communication politique afin qu'on dit
malheureusement fait partie quand même
de deux opposants au québec ont discuté
pendant très longtemps
un opposant politique historique qui
faisait la fierté à la fois des
opposants si le continent africain
mais dès qu'il a eu le pouvoir six
semaines s'est transformée si vous
voulez en une espèce de de deux
présidents qui compte est à la fois la
liberté publique et les buts et à la
liberté individuelle
au jour d'aujourd'hui je pense pour lui
le challenge pour lui s'il veut réunir
mais la guinée c'est de libérer c'est de
libérer les opposants sait de quoi
convoqué à la fois les opposants qui
sont en exil je pense que pour lui il ya
un vrai challenge le challenge de
l'unité en appel de ce décret par le
challenge en fait de l'unité clair en
raid éclair clair clair et d'éclairer
ses plus d'un c'est tellement de revenir
autour autour de la table tous les
opposants qui sont ou à la prison où
qu'ils soient en exil et peut-être voir
dans quelle condition justement ce mode
art pour tous pour lequel il est il est
nouvellement engagées jc mois soit
réduite je pense que quelque part ça va
être très très compliqué pour lui parce
qu'il est parti pour un premier mandat
du lac à thèmes les plus des salles de
nouvelles ive république et pour les
autres
qui estime qu'en fait il a fait passer
un troisième mandat mais je bute
je pense que à l'heure où je vous parle
les positions sont totalement
diamétralement opposés et qui serait
quand même compliqué d'arriver
rapidement à un consensus
merci régis okbi d'avoir été avec mon
journaliste d'investigation consultant
international merci
dans le reste de l'actualité en
centrafrique est la campagne
présidentielle bat son plein avant le
scrutin de fin décembre favoris le
président sortant faustin archange
touadéra tient de nombreux meetings de
son côté l'opposition est privée de son
leader françois bozizé qui a accepté
l'invalidation de sa candidature
aujourd'hui les explications de grâce
d'ailleurs c'est l'effervescence ce
lundi après midi sur le terrain de
l'école de go bongo dans le 4e
arrondissement de la capitale bangui
faustin archange touadéra en quête d'un
second mandat est venu à la rencontre de
ses sympathisants à la tête du pays
depuis 2016 il présente son bilan face à
un électorat en partie convaincu par la
légitimité de sa possible réélection
lorsque les poseurs de
les occasions de vibrer gosse à une
politique grâce à une offensive
diplomatique et grâce à une
détermination sans faille vous avez
aujourd'hui parce que vid ron c'est un
domaine de plus a dit le président
vaudois pour la toile passe à faustin
archange touadéra 17 candidats sont en
lice
une opposition qui avancent en ordre
dispersé depuis l'invalidation de la
candidature de son leader
l'ex président françois bozizé début
décembre la cour constitutionnelle s'est
appuyé sur un mandat d'arrêt
international pesant sur lui depuis le
31 mars 2014 pour assassinat et tortures
et sur des sanctions de l'onu
mais il n'est pas le seul à ne pouvoir
se présenter quatre autres candidatures
ont déjà été invalidée dont celle
d'armelle sayo actuel ministre de la
modernisation de l'administration afin
d'apaiser les tensions une délégation de
hauts représentants a rencontré françois
bozizé ce week-end nous avons rappelé au
président sa responsabilité en tant
qu'ancien chef d'état pour que ce
processus électoral qui est en train de
se dérouler ne se compliquent pas
davantage avec la présence des groupes
armés et que tout doit être mis en
oeuvre pour éviter la violence dans ce
pays depuis l'accord de paix du 6
février 2019
les groupes armés sont restées
étonnamment silencieux mais les milices
rebelles contrôlent encore les deux
tiers du pays ce qui fait de la question
sécuritaire l'un des principaux chevaux
de bataille du président
en quatre ans nous nous sommes investis
pour relever le défi sécuritaire qui est
le problème majeur de ce pays
[Musique]
et progressivement tout s'arrange le
retour de la sécurité en centrafrique
nous concerne tous ma détermination et
celle du gouvernement s'est traduite par
la signature de l'accord de paix avec
les groupes armés pour apporter la paix
en centrafrique pour contribuer à
l'apaisement la mission des nations
unies en centrafrique la minus cas forte
de onze mille 500 casques bleus a promis
un important dispositif
la russie a également livré une
vingtaine de blanc des anti émeutes pour
l'élection présidentielle dont la date
est prévue le 27 décembre prochain le
crâne elle souhaite inscrire le site de
tchernobyl patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco et bien vingt ans la centrale
fermer définitivement ses portes en 1986
n avait été le théâtre de l'un des
accidents nucléaires les plus terribles
de l'histoire rs raid le récit signé à
mehdi escaffit 26 avril 1986 une journée
en enfer pour les habitants de pripiat
la ville la plus proche de la
catastrophe
située à 150 kilomètres au nord de kiev
une tragédie qui entraîne la diffusion
d'une gigantesque quantité de matières
radioactives dans l'atmosphère avec des
conséquences terribles pour les
populations avoisinantes et
l'environnement
quatorze ans après l'accident à la
centrale nucléaire de tchernobyl ferme
définitivement ses portes
michail gorbatchev dirigeants
soviétiques de l'époque reviendra plus
tard sur les circonstances du désastre
la catastrophe de tchernobyl étaient
accidentels liés à une technologie
défaillantes et des erreurs humaines
les premiers rapports rester prudent et
il a fallu attendre le lendemain le 27
avril pour apprendre qu'une explosion
avait frappé une centrale nucléaire
tuant au moins deux personnes et que des
éléments radioactifs avaient été
rejetées dans l'air la zone d'exclusion
de tchernobyl s'étend sur un rayon de 30
km autour de l'ancienne centrale
les cent vingt mille habitants qui
vivaient dans les communes du territoire
concerné
n'ont jamais pu retourner chez eux
devenue emblématique le site fascine
autant qu'il intrigue entre 2018 et 2019
près de deux cent mille visiteurs se
sont rendus à pripiat transformée en
ville fantôme depuis la catastrophe
un intérêt qui poussent désormais les
autorités ukrainiennes à vouloir
inscrire tchernobyl au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco
c'est l'un des territoires les plus
emblématiques de l'ukraine
il faut le préserver pour l'humanité la
zone de tchernobyl et déjà une
attraction célèbre à travers le monde
malheureusement cet endroit n'a pas de
statut officiel l'ukraine s'apprête à
soumettre un dossier avant la fin du
mois de mars la décision finale de l'
agence de l'onu ne sera pas rendu avant
2023 et c'est la fin de cette émission
on se retrouve dans quelques instants
pour un point complet sur l'actualité
[Musique]
la chasse est un lobby donc il pèse très